hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from round one point two from
2019 3d World Cup a lot of you have
suggested it so here it is it's Peter
Svidler versus cuban grandmaster carlos
danielle albornoz cabrera and it's a
it's a really awesome game fine
miniature if you will and as my eyes
feeling much better i decided to lose
the shades so there's that and also i
would like to address something that
well some of you have been saying in the
comments that you don't enjoy the
subtitles as it covers a well a large
portion of your screen the subtitles are
not turned on by me for example i can't
turn on the subtitles and you will have
to see the subtitles you have an option
depending on which player you're using
to view the video so you can turn them
off or on I don't control that so I just
wanted to mention that so yeah that
being said let's check out this very
nice game and also there is the capo
Blanc emerge that is available some
t-shirts and some other items if you've
enjoyed the capablanca saga but we're
gonna mention that after we check out
the game so Svidler with the white
pieces opens with efore we've c5 the
Sicilian defense Knight to f3 Knight to
c6 and now Bishop to b5 the Rosalie mou
with these 6s whittler castles and the
now Bishop to d7 rook to e1 this is the
most popular way to play this Knight to
f6 and now c3 preparing d4 at some point
in the game with a6 pushing the bishop
back and now attacking the bishop back
for later Bishop to f1 and now Bishop to
g4 the bishop is no longer needed here
so it's transferred to a more useful
diagonal and now there is a one game and
probably silver check this out during
his preparation for the game but there
are a couple of nice games that Carlos
Daniel albornoz Cabrera already played
in this line one that was kind of recent
was against the Paco Vallejo in the
Linares tournament last month that ended
in a draw
where h3 was played by Paco Vallejo but
here Soler
prepares d4 and it's uh III kind of
enjoyed this line more as it forces
whites to double his pawns on the
kingside so here Bishop captures in the
now G captures on f3 of course if you
capture with the Queen then you just
lose lose upon here so not something you
want to do but after Bishop captures
with G captures now you White has a very
strong center here but on the other hand
you kind of created some draft in front
of your king but okay C capture son d4
with see capture son before and now as
you don't want to allow white to d5
black pushes d5 himself you know what we
say about Sicilian and d5 sweedler
pushes be v with Knight to h5 and now
sweedler pushes East six this game this
move has been played before but only
once I was played in 2011 between you
young G and booth young Z and that game
also ended in a draw but there F
captures an e6 was played and the game
continued Bishop to h3 and so on
ended in a draw but here after each sex
with g6 and this is now a new move so as
a move 12 we have a completely new game
so whittler continues the Knight to c3
it seems like a nice idea to capture on
f7 but black doesn't really mind this
black would just capture and if you go
Bush up to h3 you want to get some
Bishop to e6 action may be going on then
just Knight to g7 and you control e de
six squared Bishop g5 the knight is now
coming to f5 and that's that's pretty
much a monster night black has dry and
if you decide to lose your Bishop air if
you play Bishop captures G captures then
it's actually black we'll be using the G
file for an attack against the White
King even though the king is on f7
there's there's no way for white to
actually reach the king
so after g6 fiddler continues Knight to
c3 and now black pushes f5 he doesn't
want a double his pawns by capturing on
e6 and also it's not good for black but
the downside here is if you don't get
rid of the e6 pawn you your king is kind
of
could be in a lot of trouble if some
chicks go along his way
so Queen to b3 by Skylar now putting
pressure on the d5 point as well as the
b7 point and black decides okay I will
accept your challenge we have night
captures on d4 fiddler plays Queen
captures on b7 with rook to b8 Queen
captures on a6 and now you can't go for
a night to see to if you go night c2 to
try and fork the rooks you just get meat
into Queen c6 check Queen blocks and now
Queen delivers mate so Cabrera played
Knight captures on f3 with check for
king the king and the rook we have king
- h1 by cellular and now the only good
move for black here is Bishop to g7 you
have to create some escape route for
your king to hide in case of any you
know any tricks and the black did this
but black did it by playing Queen to c7
instead black freed the d8 square for
the King and this simply doesn't work so
feel free to pause the video here and
well basically try to find the move and
that is the reason why we are showing
this game as it's a very nice game while
I give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations because there are
actually two extremely good moves here
that win the game for white so for those
of you who found Bishop to f4
congratulations that's really an
outstanding move but Queen to a4 check
also does the trick so just to show you
an example silver plated Quinte for
check but Bishop f4 is also very nice
because now if Knight captures if Knight
captures then you get a queen to a4
check or all the same King to d8 now
you're gonna go Knight b5 you're gonna
attack the Queen and c7 Queen has to
move and now you're gonna go Knight to
a7 going for Knight to c6 check and now
whatever you play let's say will not
capture sunny one you're gonna go nice
e6 check you either go here to this
diagonal which loses of course and then
you could go King c8 but then Bishop d6
and now black is pretty much without a
move or whatever you play wins here on
the other hand after Bishop to f4 if you
capture with the Queen well the Queen
was
important here regarding the may threat
so just Quincy sex check King moves and
now Queen to d7 is mate
so after Queen to c7 Bishop to f4
completely winning settler played Queen
to a4 check which is also completely
winning it's just a different move order
came to d8 and now so it'll look played
Bishop to f4 so of course now you can't
capture with the Queen because it's
actually mate in one not meeting do like
in the previous line black played a
knight captures on f4 so what do you
play now night the b5 and this is an
excellent move as it kind of threatens
to go into the same line that we've
already shown but black also has the
option of capturing with the road the
capturing of the night with the rook
doesn't work but it's a beautiful line
so we're just gonna show it Bishop
captures here and now whatever black
plays it doesn't really matter you're
not you're not freeing the bishop or the
rook so let's say you capture the rook
there are no better moves the thread is
Bishop d7 now the thread is Queen to aah
check after the Queen blocks you're just
gonna capture the Queen and deliver mate
if Knight captures on e6 hoping now for
Queen check then the King can capture on
d7 you just play Bishop captures on e6
the threat is the same and now after
going to be 7 guarding this threat now
you will look the c1 again just going
for that nice c8 where and if d4
delivering this check now we just block
with the Queen and the Queen captures
rook captures then whatever move black
plays on the next when it will be his
turn then rook the c8 is mate there's
nothing black can do to prevent this so
this is only one of the one of the
things that can happen if you capture on
b5 which doesn't work for black Queen to
b6 was played
but here's fiddler found a very nice
move also you might want to pause the
video and try to figure out but I'm sure
you already know it as it's quite
similar to the line we've shown but feel
free to do it either way so for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
threatened threatened er of mates in one
while moving the night and for those of
you who just wanted your show tonight
the d4 this is what Svidler played and
it was in this position that Carlos
Daniel albornoz Cabrera resigned the
game it's better than night to a7 as it
also guards the e6 pawn so you don't
have to worry about any night captures
on e6 ideas if if you're interested how
the game might continue well of course
you have to block mate in one that's
priority so let's say Queen to c7 now
you play knight c6 check the King has to
move of course you don't want to go in
on the Queen's diagonal so King to c8
now you play Bishop to a6 check similar
similar like in that line only we don't
win the Queen
Ruby 7 Bishop characters Queen captures
and now just rook a to c1 you don't even
care about this rook anyone but there
aren't no good defensive moves here
let's say Knight d2 trying to cover up
with Knight to c4 now you just go Knight
a5 check and you well you win the Queen
if Knight to c4 blocking you don't even
have to grab the Queen you can just go
for Queen to e8 check first King c7 and
now you're gonna go king the Queen d7
check King b6 for example now you're
gonna capture the Queen with check King
captures on a5 and now it's just rook
captures captures and now a4 and you are
getting made it on b5 or if you don't
want to get made a nun be 5 you can
capture the pawn and then it's rook to a
one mate so this is only one of the
nicer lines that could happen after
night to d4 check but after this move
Cabrera resign resign the game and an
excellent victory for Peter Svidler who
advances into the next round of the FIBA
World Cup where he will face andrey
dubenko so that will also be an
interesting matchup
i'm gonna go back to checking out your
suggestions of course as there are so
many of them I don't think it would be
possible to cover all of them and for
those of you who said that you would
like to see who advances in the next
round there are too many players as it's
only round one for me to go over them
but I will put a link in the description
below so you can just click on it and
you will see the cross table of everyone
who advanced into the second round
so that's it that's the game
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Deepak but Matthew Harris and the
Jeffrey Johnson for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here I think all
for watching and I will see you soon
well continuing the coverage of the
feeder World Cup checking up on your
suggestions and what's going on in the
world and if you are interested in some
capablanca saga merchandise the first
link in the description below will take
you to it so feel free to enjoy that as
well thank you all I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day